hello good evening and welcome to
scitrek your sci-fi tv and movie channel
i've just come on scene to do a bit of a
live video because
about star game basically because
i don't know about you guys but i feel
like something is happening with targets
at the moment
um you also if you're a regular
sidetracker you know everything that
i've been talking about for the last few
months
but today
over the last couple of days joseph
malusi has started being a little bit
more open and talking about
stargate
he today released the um front page it
doesn't actually same thing as a
stargate
series title blacked out and then
basically
series one episode
this is the front page of brad wright's
script
for skyler for the pilot show
um he's also tweeted or responded to a
couple of tweets some guy asking him are
we gonna find a response for you know an
actual end to sgu are we gonna find out
what happened to stargate atlantis after
you know it was just left in the middle
of san francisco bay hi shelley how are
you
good evening
um
john c you are right it cannot
the thing is i feel like something is
about to happen right now if you are a
regular sidetracker you'll know that
um i've said that there are big meetings
happening in november
so i'm sorry big meetings did happen in
november and eight meetings are gonna
happen now april april 4th
a lot of big executives from mgm and
amazon are going to be at those meetings
stuff is going to start being decided in
those meetings they're going to start
looking at the projects that they've won
already got in motion which there are a
lot of projects in the motion already
and then gonna start thinking about
green lighting moving forwards because
at mgm a lot has been on hold in the
last few months basically for the last
year
so all of a sudden amazon who completely
controls mgm can start actually signing
some checks and getting some money spent
that's what we want
now
i've been told repeatedly um get into
the comments tell me if you want me to
go over how the sources and why i
started talking about stargate in the
first one
um
because i could do that again but i've
basically been told by people i work
with at um i know sorry that work in and
around mgm
that actually i'm amazing really really
fine stargate to be in one of the big
three projects they want to push forward
with
now melody starting talking about this
today
does seem to i don't know it just feels
like something is starting to get going
some momentum is starting
right so
the sources i start speaking to
about eight months ago when i started
sidetrack and i did a video on um how
amazon were about so how mgm were
planning to bring back stargate
a live action tv series and an animated
tv series now this was based on a story
by giant freaking robot that got spread
everywhere um and i fell for it not
realizing the giant freaking robot are a
bunch of click-baiting idiots but anyway
i then got a message from just somebody
randomly they basically said this story
isn't true it was about six months ago
or a year ago before the old executive
in charge of um scripted work at baby
fiction work and lost his job and was
replaced by um steve wright
um when steve wright came in he
basically said
we can't do an animated series we've got
skills to do in our major series and
nobody wants to see that crap anyway so
let's just go with the um live action
series
um and basically by then amazon dealer
started to go through anyway so
everything got put on pause
i responded to this chat because i tried
to respond to as many messages i can but
something about this message though as
well was so sort of like determined you
know he was he wasn't just sort of
saying i don't think that he was he was
like no this is this now it's true now
it's not that's true anymore
so i responded to him i got chatting to
him
now it turns out this person
doesn't actually work directly for mgm
but he works for a company
close to mgm that does a lot of legal
contracts and things like that so he
gets to see a lot of what's going on i
keep saying he i'm not actually saying
whether to he or she i'm sorry i'm
trying to protect this person's identity
but i keep saying he out of habit sorry
um
he basically gets to see a lot of what
mgm are doing through the contracts that
they're putting forwards
so it's contracts for everything
employment contracts
the person that cleans up on the sets
the person that does the you know like
the food trucks and props and then blah
blah blah all of this has to have a
contract
and all of this goes through this one
company there's two or three companies
actually do work for mgm doing this
through that chap he then got me in
touch with somebody that actually does
work directly for
uh mgm
you're very welcome i'm doing my best
and that is the cutest dog um
and um who one person that works
actually with the um is it
involving the creative side of things
one person i cannot tell you what they
do because it's quite a specific job and
if i give you any details about this
person i think they would be able to be
identified
um i have got a funny story to tell you
about that in a second which i will and
a fourth person that again doesn't
actually work directly for mgm but works
for a company that does do work for mgm
they actually also do work for disney
and a few other companies and it's to do
with technology and stuff
i'm basically an i.t geek
um
so
will the new stargate have more
diversity
probably because we know that's the way
it goes but there's quite a lot of
diversity in stargate sg-1 and atlantis
anyway i mean there's quite a lot of um
lots of different ethnicities in that so
i don't really think that's a that's a
problem
um
so
um
there's one place so basically yes
that's those the four people i now speak
to regularly and the one chap in
particular has been a bit of a gold mine
for information because he gets to see
lots of bits of things going on
tonight i'm going to try to go through
though in a second what do we know for
certain and what's rumor
because i know at times i have done
videos and i've got quite excited about
the video um and i just tell you guys
because it's coming from mgm it's coming
from sources close to mgm
so i i just tell you i think even though
that's a rumor it's a rumor coming from
a pretty good source
um it's information that is knocking
around mgm so we'll try to go through
and figure out what's actual
fact
and what is
rumor but rumor from a
pretty big place jason momoa is one of
my favorite actors and i always knew
mark that he was going to be massive as
soon as he just had big grin in stargate
atlantis i think he just everybody knew
he was going to be massive and i think
he's just great for everything he does
and good good evening a regular
sidetracker thank you for joining
so
what do we know for fact
so or at least what we know from fact
from what i've told mgm
there were meetings in november between
amazon and mgm executives
at that point they did that was mostly
business meetings i have to admit but
executives in charge of these things did
meet and did discuss certain projects
at those meetings they did the amazon
executives did raise concerns
that brad wright's script for the pilot
wasn't maybe grand enough that it was
written at a time when mgm was still two
billion quid in debt owned by their
debtors
and it was written to a budget this guy
remember this script this pilot script
is namely three years old
um so they just raised those concerns
since then
um basically
conceptual art and for a um
for the script the hero to the initial
script um basically what's this what we
doing preliminary rough storyboarding
has been done
and some concept art for these pitch
meetings they're going to be happening
in april early april starting from april
4th
that now we do know or i've been told
that at least one day and some point
next week or the week after has
basically been put upside for two or
three projects and stargate is one of
them
and there will be pitch meetings those
days where this
very early preliminary storyboarding and
some concept art is going to be
presented and used as part of the pitch
to these executives
now
we do know as well that there are two
scripts that this is being done by so
basically they're doing concept art and
very preliminary storyboarding for two
pilots brad wright's pilot and another
one
now i've been told but this is this bit
is a rumor the joseph melosi's name is
attached in some way to that second
script it doesn't necessarily mean he
wrote it
but in some way it's attached to it
so that part is a rumor but we know
these meetings are going to be happening
something else we actually do know
and has been sort of semi-confirmed by
brad wright is that amanda tapping and
michael shanks have both been approached
to appear in this new series
um michael shanks has also been
approached to possibly direct episodes
and amanda tapping
according to my source has been
approached to do a lot more than that to
potentially be um a producer maybe even
executive producer on the tv show by the
way if you've got a drink
crack on all right because i'm gonna
wet the whistle
sunday night linda day i've got no work
tomorrow so happy days
so
that's what we know um is in fact those
things have happened these people have
been approached and brad wright is
pretty much um
staggered which means to pick the
football teams
i'd take michael shanks with my first
pick and then it would be jason um
so some also things that we do know at
the moment is that amazon have actually
sent out a bunch of surveys in the last
two weeks
those surveys um it's something they do
all the time they love meta information
they love data they love anything they
put in a graph basically
and those surveys have asked do you like
watching stargate original and do you
want to see more stargates as in new
stargate i've had two three
four subscribers now come to me and
actually show me this service so i know
that's actually happened
the rumors though get a bit more
um fuzzy because people hear things
knocking around the offices
um how do i get in touch with my contact
is i did just say but um the first
contact he actually messaged me
and he just left the comp he just left a
comment on the video i did the video
actually did the um got me noticed
basically it has had like a hundred
thousand views and it's embarrassing so
it's got a hundred thousand views and a
video that's wrong
which is quite frustrating um but yeah
he just contacted me this chap has
actually said to me as well um that he
has actually contacted gabe world and
they've left comments on gay world
messages
but
they they never answered they don't
reply so i don't if you've ever left
messages on some of these larger
facebook and user youtube channels they
don't really require a great deal and i
try to reply to everybody um
panther pickle let's just confirm that's
that's great that's you're my fifth
person that has told me that so that's
great so we know that's happening
so yeah they got touching me um and then
he helped me through
through other sources to to like say
make this little bit of a network um i
am actually speaking to somebody new as
well that works reasonably closely with
disney but again it's one of these
people that sort of like works in and
around it doesn't actually work directly
for disney themselves
i was just going to mention actually
sidetrack has actually been mentioned in
a memo apparently
this is this is quite funny i quite like
this
there was apparently a memo put around
um and a lot of mgm employees got
basically saying to remind them not to
speak to
in creators youtube creators and youtube
channels gateworld was obviously
mentioned so you do not speak to these
people you're not allowed to you might
be reminding them this about the ndas
but apparently
according to this chap sidetrack was
mentioned which if it's true my piddly
little channel got mentioned in an mgm
thing if that's true
that's made my month i would love that
to be true um i'd say they've told me it
is but
who knows
so
moving back to the
rumors
one of the rumors we've got is that a
royal denmark actually in the november
meetings did apparently pitch
and i have to have two or three pitch
meetings to mgm talking about projects
he wants to do in the future and things
like this but one of the things he
apparently did was pitch the original
stargate trilogy that he planned so the
stargate movie the original ronca
russell and etc was and written by dean
devlin and produced by ronald rick was
supposed to be a trilogy
um back uh
a few years after before the movie
started rolling emerick was hoping to
make um the sequel but obviously they
decided to go with the tv series instead
now
actually about 2006 i think it was
somebody before you correct me um
they've considered doing this again it
was going to be a hard reboot and
they're actually going to make the
original stargate movie again and then
the second and third movies
now at the time
i believed that actually and i was told
that this was done because they were
considering a hard reboot again and
apparently it is something that's been
discussed but excuse me it's not
something that is um considered to be
a very good idea by amazon and ronald
rick actually kind of confirmed this in
an interview about six weeks ago where
he said
they don't want to make a movie at mgm
they consider the tv audience to be more
important and they don't want to make a
film
they're not interested and i'm not
interested in making a movie
but if they do make a film i'll have to
be attached in some way roland denrick
said because um of contracts so he'd be
contracted in some way to work with mgm
if they reproduced a stargate movie
now i've been told that there's always
been a plan a and a plan b
um plan a basically if the sale went
through quickly enough was to actually
produce a movie first
and then produce a tv series now roland
emerick's pitch was not actually to do
with that movie but what it was to do
with was
basically the first series of sg-1 the
first three or four series of sg-1 were
based around
roughly what happened in the first
stargate film
what they want to do starting off with
this new series is it have it roughly
based around what should have happened
in the second movie
now i've been told that the villain in
this is going to be the anunnaki which
you can go and google them and find out
all about them
but
that would be quite rough i think and i
think it would be inspired by the story
of the annunaki and these first gods
that the sumerians talked about
i don't see it being much more than that
though because i mean even the egyptian
myths and things were inspiration but
then obviously became um the stargate
mythology that we know me and and you
know it's only very very loosely based
on history
so
moving forwards amazon would like to do
a movie now i'm asked why
because
it does seem to me the streaming
networks are moving away from movies a
lot they um you know we get big action
we get big movie stars now in these
streaming series you know jason manohar
mode did um sorry i was called um on
apple tv um chris evans is about to do a
mini series i forget what it's called um
and
you know so um
that's happening a lot these mini series
of like 10 hours or 10 episodes are like
long movies now they've got they've got
the budget of movies they've got like 15
million dollars of an episode is what's
being like the netflix's in the air last
airbender series which is going to be a
massive flop i suspect and it's 15
million dollars an episode you know just
put that in perspective stargate sg-1
had um a
budget of about eight hundred thousand
dollars an episode when it was first
made it was one of the reasons why wrong
number had no interest in doing he said
there was not no near enough money to
make what he wanted to do so he wasn't
gonna do it
um we all know what the lord of the
rings is costing and whether we want to
watch that or not is another thing
let's keep this on stargate
um
so
they would like to do a movie first now
i'm told they want to do a movie first
though because that would be a lot more
hype
so
and that's what they want they want to
build up a lot of excitement about the
tv series that would then follow
i'm not 100 if that's still the plan
um
because now there seems to be more and
more talk about the tv series and i get
little rumors and things that i do here
seem to be a little bit more
they're looking at basically what um
faye is doing with the mandalorian
series and the book of boba fett and
apparently that's quite liked they quite
like that and a lot of people around mgm
have been talking about maybe that's how
the future would be where you get lots
of little serious interlink with each
other you know like boba fett is very
much interlinked with mandalorian in
fact you could argue actually i would
argue very straight out saying the best
two episodes of boba fett were the ones
that hadn't bob effect not in them and
mandalorian was focused but the stories
interlinked with each other
and that's basically
what he said this chap i speak to mgm he
suspects stargate might end up being
basically it's like lots of series that
run ten episodes but we might get two or
three series a year
different titles different stories
different bases but they interlink with
each other
and this is something amazing this
interlinking idea is actually something
they really really want to do
um
not just they want to link the movies
with the tv series if they if they make
movies but also with things like the
game
now i've been told that when timekeepers
comes out this game that stargate is
about to release
that it's going to give us a lot of
information about what the then project
will be because amazon are quite keen
forever brad wright or whoever ends up
doing with stargate that it links back
to the game and links in with the game
and we know from
what we've seen very early on about
timekeepers is that um it's going to be
very much a tiny whiny type of thing
it's going to jump around through
stargate sg1 atlantis maybe even
universe
and then um
i forgot to put my mods in today but
we're getting um some unpleasantness in
the
comments
block user thank you very much
um so um
so yeah we'll see what happens with that
but this idea of the interlinking
basically as well the other thing is
amazon look like what marvel are doing
and they love it
they really really want
marvel type project
where it's not not in the style not in
the way it's made
um but in the way they release material
obviously the movies interlink with the
tv series they all build up on each
other but also having these phases where
you'd have a bad guy over two or three
years say but all the different projects
yeah they're trying to take us down but
they'll they'll never shut me up i'm i'm
not going to show up by this crap all
right um
all these all the inter projects would
sort of build up to
sort of a thanos moment you know and
then they would move on to the next
phase
and um it seems to be that again that's
the sort of thing mgm are talking about
a lot not just for stargate but for
other projects as well um anything sort
of these big sort of projects they want
to do that they hope to have that sort
of interlinked sort of way of doing it
which i think is is obviously probably
the way to go and probably what they'll
do because then again they're following
what marvel have done
and and what disney are doing with
disney plus and that's what amazon prime
want to become
i'd love you guys to get into the
comments by the way
just tell me what you guys think about
brad wright
does he have to lead
this new project because a lot of people
say to me that they either want it
um
i'm pretty confident we're going to get
i'll come back to that in a second if
that's okay
um
get into the comments so talk about
brand right just for a second
and then we'll talk about what's going
to be happening over the next couple of
months if brad wright isn't involved in
stargate do you think that's a massive
problem or
i'm not a massive fan sgu
if you've done it in my channel before
you'll know that i'm not a huge
fan
and
so
i think he dropped the ball i think he
basically saw battlestar galactica and
he copied the style in lots of ways and
he wanted to make something that was a
lot heavier a lot more drama
um and and i and i think he failed i
think he was born even though it was
getting a lot better towards the end
it failed because it was kind of boring
um that's my own personal opinion saga
sg1 is my favorite show ever
you know um but
sgd wasn't
and i think that showed in the feeling
figures and why he got cancelled also
was a massively expensive show to make
um
i would agree with that completely too
heavy too dark great acting
but it was an incredibly expensive
project
um
so
if brad wright wasn't the lead
would that be a problem now
joseph malozzi has released this front
to sing the script now i've said a few
times and brad wright goes on his
companion podcast talks a lot about
stargate i think a lot he's been trying
to strong-arm amazon and mgm
i think if he
was a dead cert to make the show and he
knew he was going to be able to make
this show he wouldn't be saying anything
because the studio's not wanting to be
talking on podcasts about stargate and
talking about these things
um
that you know you they always have a
kona style in some of these projects
until the green light until they have
their official announcement
um
so why is jose joseph melody talking why
is brad right talking
personally this is not in my opinion
i think they're talking because they're
not 100 certain that they're going to
get their hands on this project and
they're going to lose it and amazon
don't necessarily want them to be
involved
or at the very least
if they are in charge
um
it won't be they won't have the control
they want now
one way they could get the control they
want
is by getting us on site
simple as that
so um
if they can get the fans on site and we
can get um and we basically demand it
it really makes
um
them saying no a lot harder they really
it really makes
um
amazon
then if amazon mgm then announce that
somebody else is going to be running the
show it's going to have to be somebody
like amanda tapping or we're going to
lose our minds you know
um
ian's got a good point there though
maybe it is time for some fresh blood
how would you guys feel about that if
they did come out with somebody who's
completely new like imagine now brad
wright is sacked he's so he's not going
to be involved
but amanda tapping is going to be show
runner and she has sure on other shows
the show she's doing at the moment she's
the showrunner she's been executive
produced on a couple of things
do you think that could work do you
think people could get behind that
because i actually think people would
be really up for that
my worry is that the girl they'll do
what basically they did with star trek
a new leader will come in a new show
runner will come in and they will mold
it away and they will change things for
the sake of changing it because that's
sometimes they they want to put their
stamp on it don't they want to put that
in they want to be you know like this is
what um we you know this is this is what
we want to do so they'll change the
klingons and they'll do something else
and they'll they'll miss the ships and
then the style of the show will change
they'll tell themselves they're
modernizing it
but what they're really doing is just
going to annoy us
now they will have to modernize some
things because technology's moved on the
way we do things is is going to be
different now
um
you know the the technology of how they
make the ships and you know the model in
the 3d model and all this sort of thing
it's different now so it's going to look
a bit different
um
i would agree though it's got to be
somebody who knows the show it's got to
be somebody who loves the show and it's
got to be somebody that understands the
canon because it seems to me with star
trek the guy that runs it at the moment
knows the canon but doesn't care enough
to actually
like really stick to it now i
i'm not a massive one on star
um on costa rica cannon being really
really strict
and they mess with cannon all the time
for the story to move the story along
for the plot
but
there's a line you know there's there's
so much you can fiddle with and mess
around with or sometimes they just make
they just bloody make mistakes
but there's got to be a line there's
only so long you can go before you know
um it starts getting really irritating
like j.t abrams making the enterprise
massive just because he thought it would
look better on screen that's not good
enough they shouldn't be allowed to do
that and my fear is that that could
happen with stargate if they bring in
completely new blood
so i would prefer
if it was somebody like amanda tapping
that loves the show and that would
control it i would also be more than
happy for brad wright to come in as the
show runner he doesn't necessarily have
to write the shows and these things he
didn't write a lot of sg-1 anyway joseph
malozzi and ronaldinho and people like
this did
but he he should come in and maybe
oversee it you know like with marvel
having somebody in charge is a good idea
and have somebody making sure the ship
stays on the right track is a good idea
um
but they do that with star trek and look
at this show that is
um
yeah thanks for commenting on this one
yeah treasure in space i'm not there why
not um
i love the idea as well that um
we can see something completely
different now brad wright is obviously
going along the ideas of the stargate is
an open secret now and i've done a video
you guys go back and have a look if you
didn't see it about the dangers of that
you know that there's a lot of
we want star trek not stargate no we
want stargate not star trek sorry
um you know um
too much technology too much power in
humans we need a villain that's still
going to make us
the plucky underdog or it's just going
to be star trek and i don't want to
watch that
you know we're going to have starships
we're going to be
off world a lot more you know it's not
going to be the same as what it was and
we have to be prepared for the fact that
when stargate returns it's not going to
be the same
good evening daniel a new subscriber i
am very very happy to see you um
one thing i'm going to talk about
stargate universe really quickly is that
i get asked a lot
will stargate universe get an end and
i'm actually going to do a video about
it in the next few days um where i'll go
through my ideas a lot more but
um
joseph malozzi basically said today that
if brad wright's project gets done we
will get to find out where stargate
atlantis is
and we will get to find out something
with stargate universe now i personally
don't ever see
that um it could be
um
starting universe thing is gonna have a
happy ending but maybe they could go and
at least get some of those people back
get eli back you know go save them but
that could be sort of like a serious
finale or a mid-season you know if we
got what would it be nice if we got like
a 22 episode season one wouldn't that be
nice
um and like a mid-season big
you know the big mid-season episode was
they actually figured out a way to go
and save the destiny crew you know how
incredible would that be
um i don't think that's where they'll do
it but
but joseph pelosi has concerned that
they want to have an answer to what
happened to universe and to go beyond
the comics i don't know if they'll stay
as canon or that goes beta kind of
basically ignore them but actually what
happened in the comics was um
was pretty straightforward actually
really understandable so um i don't see
any reason why i shouldn't be able to do
that gotta remember is there's been 20
years since sg-1 ended nearly so you
know they're 20 years further on those
points i made in one of the videos i did
a few weeks ago was actually think about
where they went from start of sg-1
technologically-wise to the end of
stargate sg1 10 years we went from
basically not really understanding how
the gates worked
to having starships
with asgard weapons you know they went a
long way over a 10-year period um and
you know
where they're going to be now 20 years
on
i don't
know july
so
the 25th anniversary of sg-1 coming onto
our screens
is going to be in uh july
now i've been told and i'm pretty
confident about this
that they are trying really hard to get
something on our screens so basically
the moment in the uk anyway you can't
get sg one
you can't watch it on amazon prime you
can only watch it through the mgm
channel and then you have to pay for it
um stargate universe used to be on there
but i think that's been kind of i think
it's just the first series of first and
seconds here yeah i think just for the
series
stargate francis was on there that's
gone as well
so in the uk at least can't watch it
i have to have to buy them
sdg cards things unfaithfully sgm yeah
they work great and thank you for the um
super chat
um i've read the sg comics where it was
a while ago and actually quite like them
for somebody that didn't actually like
the series i thought those comics were
actually quite clever i loved how they
sort of brought in the original
engineers that they were actually in
stasis because i never thought about
that during the film doing the series
i'm sure that's where they were going to
go in the series but of course there'd
be people in stasis on that ship that
they that they haven't seen yet queen
cop total sense so if you've not seen
the comics give it a go they're actually
really really good
so this 25th anniversary though
one of the things
that really is we're going to have to
see
um is getting stargate back on amazon
prime
we have to remember the stargate movie
is the 10th highest grossing mgm movie
of all time
you know
you won't believe that considering the
type of things and the movies mgm have
done over the years but it's the 10th
highest grossing movie
stargate sg-1 the franchise
as a value as a commodity to mgm is
second only to james bond
it's the it's the most valuable
franchise
there is absolutely no way
that amazon prime will not take
advantage of that
um i could actually see them doing some
sort of documentary
um
put something together quickly i've had
no news on that so that's just again my
opinion but i could completely see
amazon releasing some sort of
documentary about saga sg1 talking about
how amazing it was over the 10 years
remembering at the time it was um
exactly it's not that is the point
though isn't it people will pay for
scripture well i'm going to talk about
subscriptions in a second
let me make a note of that because
that's a really important point
why these shows are going to get made
um so
what's my train of thought
i keep seeing raising comments and i
keep losing my train thought but sorry
so yeah the 25th anniversary i can see
i'm doing some sort of documentary or
something
um
and then releasing stargate sg1 maybe in
an upgraded like 4k version maybe
digitally enhanced if they've got time
but this that's a big problem it's what
are they going to have time to do
because we're talking about only what is
it three months or something until the
anniversary
but what
what amazon can do
is green light stargate project by that
time frame
so
one way of getting
some
excitement
you put stargate sg1 back in amazon
prime you make a big deal of it
and at the same time maybe in the same
day you announce
that it's there that that we are going
to have stargate back in our screens
maybe you know
we could see something like that they
could announce the movie is going to get
made or they can announce the tv show is
going to get made at the end of the day
that would explode the internet and
that's what they want because they want
clicks that's what they want they want
people
doing this what we're talking about on
here they want us talking about it they
want hashtag bring back star trek and
pick star trek don't bring back start oh
god
does anybody else really enjoyed the
first episode of card and now hate it
that's not just me
um
bring back stargate you know if this is
a hashtag we should all use you know we
really want this show back and if we
demand it they will make it
because they all they hear is cha-ching
shing
how they make it whether they do a
decent project or not
is a completely different story because
i actually fear
i i actually do worry about stargate
coming back
we want stargate yes we do
well we can talk about work in a little
while
but um
i have different views on work and i do
worry about it but yeah
um bring back stargate
get in there
so
subscriptions
there's a war going on at the moment
between disney plus amazon prime
hulu in america
and paramount plus are the new boys
um hbo max
and it's a war basically for
subscribers
um
the normal way of watching tv is dead
it's going
i'm absolutely saying this is the main
reason why babylon 5 has been um why
they didn't go through that onto the cw
is because hbo max want it
um they want shows that are going to get
them subscribers they want big projects
things like
um stranger times and strange things
sorry that's my friend stranger times
um and a channel that you must go and
have a look at i'll put a link in the
description later but yeah stranger
things shows like that
drag in
people anything to get a buzz and get to
talk to and get people excited
gets
people to them join the channel and once
people join things like netflix they
very rarely cancel them
it's like your gym membership that
you're still paying for from three years
ago when on new year's eve you really
really thought it was a good idea to
start going to the gym again and you
accepted the direct debit and you never
canceled it because you can't be
bothered a lot of people still do that
even with things like netflix i actually
had the disney plus subscription when it
first came out for over a year
um
and that isn't exactly the expense is a
perfect show like that
um
nothing was on disney plus for the first
year once the fox stuff came in
and it's it's blown up now and it is
there's great stuff on disney plus
but for the first year there wasn't
really it's just a bunch of disney
movies but i still pay for the
description so i couldn't be bothered to
cancel it
um people fall for that and that's
that's a lot of people do that and
that's what they want they want people
to get excited
to go on to amazon prime and then they
know a good chunk of those people will
never cancel that subscription
excuse me
so
that's what they want and shows like
stargate will bring subscriptions
now this is one of the reasons why the
expanse will probably return in some way
not because it's massively popular but
because the people that do love it love
it
i mean they're obsessed with it
so
fans will follow that fans will follow
the
the show basically if it's like babylon
5 has a massive
old-school fan base people that
absolutely adore babylon 5 and babylon 5
show it's a cult show
if they get that hbo max they will see a
spike in subscriptions because people
will follow it
and that is absolutely amazing you know
that people will do that but that's the
way these shows work
that's the way subscription channels now
work because people follow and then they
don't unsubscribe it's not like a
network where you can just turn it off
people don't
so they keep the subscription
please get into the comments now and say
anything else that you want to ask or
you want to talk about
highlight it we'll get on to it i'll
just have a quick now
about
the surveys we've done movies time
frames we've done we're going to roll
the name right feelings
the failings okay
i have a little bit of news on that
so the furlings were was supposed to be
if you don't know i imagine if you're
watching this you do know um one of the
the most ancient races so um you know so
damn the knox
the asgard and the ancients
but we never really got to see the
feelings actually we never got to see
the feelings at all even though we got
an imagining of what the feelings were
um
yeah amazon are not stupid they know
that it's one of the biggest regular
streams it's their biggest it's going to
be a massive franchise they will do
um even though
um o'neil imagine the failings as
basically like ewoks we never actually
got to see them
now
the one chap i do speak to a lot at mgm
he's to do the creative side
he's told me that actually there is
concept art for the feelings
that brad wright in what would have been
series 11 if they hadn't got cancelled
was going to potentially bring the
feelings in and we were going to see
them and some concept art was done
now apparently
that concept art has been dragged out of
the archives and people have been
looking at it
now why i don't know
um is the furlings going to be in
they probably are they probably were
fury um
you know the other feeling is going to
be coming back into this are there going
to be something to do with
the risk of the anunnaki maybe is it
going to be something to do with the
feelings on why the anunnaki returned to
earth or returned to our galaxy or
whatever and it's an interesting concept
all i know is again
they've been
thought they all they are being thought
about
um
i am not aware that chris judge has been
spoken to in any way the only people i
am i'm aware of
um is um
man's tapping and
michael shanks definitely
um but apparently there have been some
rumors that um
um richard anderson will make some sort
of at least
passing visit if brad wright's project
gets done i don't think he'll be in the
show but i think we'll see oh no we're
not in the show properly but i think
we'll see his face
um but as far as i'm aware no one else
has been approached
even though i think genuinely the um
oh i've forgotten his name
someone against the comments please
target atlantis the colonel
um i think he would be approached i know
he's somebody that absolutely adored um
uh ben pereira you are right ian ben
browder has apparently been approached
as well
um
matthew just join in anywhere in the
ancient prequel you mentioned some weeks
ago also will you post this live stream
so we can watch the full stream later it
will be posted it gets posted
automatically
um so
um to answer your questionnaire the
prequel apparently that is something
again that is being knocked around as an
idea
um that is one of those things that is
more towards the rumor area
so lots of things will get talked about
in the offices when any sort of big
company like mgm particularly in the
creative department it doesn't
necessarily mean we're gonna that any of
that will see the light of day
because at the end of the day executives
have got to get together and write
checks and if they don't write checks
stuff don't get made
but that doesn't mean
i'd love to see my k back as well and
that doesn't mean
it's not talked about and these ideas
aren't thrown around
one of the ideas at the moment is that
if
i think this sort of goes back to the
star trek thing as well that that sort
of cop we want to copy start or they
look at what what they're doing with
star trek and of course do that with
stargate and i wish they frickin
wouldn't because i hate prequels
but actually a stargate prequel would be
quite cool i think
um
because we've got literally millions of
years of stories to tell they could make
little 10
10 episode series about different bits
through time
and never master cannon they could just
add to the story we we've seen little
bits of information
with very little effort very little
thinking really they could go in and do
something with stargate an ancients
prequel series
um
without messing anything up without
annoying the fans and would just love it
don't mean they wouldn't have to
necessarily be um
you know there wouldn't have to be big
big serious big storylines big story
arcs but you know something really early
i'd love to see
more about how they ascended
when did we get to the point
you know with
with them that the ascension's happening
we know these tensions also happened
over millions of years
things like the ori um how that sort of
that separation happened would be really
interesting sort of like you know um to
get that story and find out what
happened the other thing is the plague
that would be a brilliant little little
mini series talking about how the plague
happened
and and how um then the ancient sort of
reignited life in the milky way stuff
that would be you know a fantastic
storyline and um you know something that
could be really really dramatic
um all they have to do is make it you
know and it's it's there's so much story
there
but to answer the question no i haven't
heard anything else since
um it is sort of very much in the room
area
um
and
if it happens then um i think it would
be very much dependent on how successful
whatever the new first project
um
i would i would agree and more stories
as well i think that would be fantastic
because i how the wraith happened again
as well be really interesting before
they went into their you know the first
war the ancients would be really
instantly
um john sheppard joe flanagan thank you
sir
um look sorry just told us that thank
you
joe fan again i can't remember anything
he was so involved in trying to bring
stargate back a few years ago probably
before his name but um right so
um there isn't anything on um that
a janistory soccer atlantis would be
really good why not exactly
um
thank you for the contribution
so moving on yeah that's more under the
rumor area
um
[Music]
yeah we need to get into these sort of
the questions now really because so get
your questions up there there production
got actually wanted to deal with south
chris michael anthony lost a lot of
money yes i i did hear about that at the
time that was a lot of money got lost
there
um
ian we've just mentioned that but um i i
do think that is a way to go with that
also i think a movie could really work
well with that as well an ancient
prequel movie um something very specific
around how the first gate you know first
gates were built
um
a stargate universe multiverse we've
already seen that some episodes in some
series so you know we saw some
technology that allowed for um a
multiverse things in different scenarios
i just hope no idiot thinks to use that
like they used it with star trek
and go let's let's go through a black
hole have a completely different
universe where the enterprise is 50
times bigger um let's hope then don't do
that because i want to see a continuity
i don't want to see a hard reboot i want
to see a continuity and i do not want to
see them do a hard reboot because they
do some sort of
weird tiny whimey change thing i think
it's lazy and it annoys me
um
i actually think flanagan was the
highlight of stargate atlantis and with
jason mama
a couple of other characters are
actually quite forgettable
in that um series
but um
jason momoa and fein again were
fantastic and i would love to see if i
can come back that is a good thing
something jason joseph melosi said today
are we going to see characters from
stargate return
if they do this thing where they
intertwine it and they want to
intertwine with the game
and they do some sort of tiny whiny
episodes maybe where because we know you
could time travel with the stargate so
it could happen
um
then
maybe we can actually see characters
from across all of the series we just
don't know
um i think a time series where they
somehow use atlantis to rescue
this like other slogan i'm not quite
sure how that would work
and some some people said to me that um
there's a theory that basically that
these two projects were in competition
with each other the building of the
destiny and the building of the city
ships
but actually they were millions of years
apart
and so they wouldn't have been um in
competition with each other so um
i'm not quite sure how the atlantis
would be used
but
the time you want me is doctor who i do
love doctor who i used to love doctor
who and it just things like that stick
in my head sometimes but yeah
let's have a look back through same
thing um i want to see a free jaffa
empire attack earth liberated and gold
take over a resource of their own
liberation
we saw a lot of political angst with
jaffa nation there's a completely new
nation and they're trying to
and find their way
we also you know have the um lucian
alliance and where that might go the
only thing i would say with that is the
ships that we now control
um are so much more powerful than the
gold world attacks and things that you
know they would get absolutely blasted
you know the asgard ships that we got um
you know
that they would cut through the gold
shields like they're like not hot knife
through butter so the lucian alliance i
imagine even though they've got better
numbers than us
if they've got any sense
stay clear i'm just gonna just negate
over 352 moves for a reboot continuation
is a way to go for them i would
completely agree with you there that
and
everything i've been told
another thing i've been told recently
actually is that the mgm employees were
very very nervous
about this deal at first
they thought them coming in was going to
be um a nightmare but as it turns out
everything they're being told seems to
be really good there's been no large job
cuts amazon haven't come in and you know
like got rid of people
mgm is going to be allowed to continue
to operate quite
independently
and this is a merger mgm as a company
still exists there's the executives are
still in charge there
obviously amazon write the checks now
but
the mgm staff that i speak to and the
people in around it seem very
um
confident
that um they're actually going to be
allowed to get on with get on with it
i i believe that to a point
um i think that at the end of the day
whatever mgm do
um
it's going to be it's going to have to
it's going to be amazon's whim
thoughts on the atlantic storyline from
the comic con ancient empires on the
moon multiple styles of gates easy way
to start series and a former that is
actually something i've built into i
have used mars i don't know if you guys
remember i'm trying
very hard and then thank you for the
contribution um i'm trying to write fan
fiction
and my fan fiction and what i want to do
so i keep getting you guys to sort of
decide where we're going and i've got as
far as the uh the hammond is on its way
to mars and there's been um a gay tax or
some sort of energy activation that's
going to end up being a game
um but on a city ship
uh but the gate is connected to a
different gate network
so or it's like a super gate network so
actually connects galaxies and and
connects far
far more distant sorting
so that's but that's as far as i've got
um but yeah that's kind of stolen from
the comic books a little bit um but
tell me what you guys think though do
what you think about beta cannon do you
think that we ignore beta cannon because
it's going because there's been so many
books and things written as well
um
it's you know hello from france liberty
ever i can't say your name
learn media for uh i hate i really
struggle names um
an nid series would be fantastic
especially i think we're in a world at
the moment where we really don't trust
that government
um you know we almost
i think trust in the government is an
all-time low
an interest in sci-fi and aliens and
things like that is a pretty much an
all-time high with anything that's
supernatural and things
so show like that that was
um sort of like a secret
black ops thing
i think people would really get on board
with um i think they'll definitely be
involved that's one of the things what i
loved about sg one though wasn't it that
that they actually had that political
element that you know the the senator or
the the thing would keep coming in
trying to shut them down they keep
trying to talk about budgets and budget
meetings and things i always love that
and then like the nid came in
um
chris wright will they introduce new
alien um races or revisit species in a
series that they didn't expand on i
honestly think they'll do both
um
[Music]
like the one that impersonated an sgt
member yes of course brilliant episode
um so i i think that'd be a bit of both
like i said the rumor is that there's
going to be a new big villain
um i do think we'll get to see the
feelings at some point it sounds like um
and i think they'll try to expand under
the series like the gold and things i
think i could see the gold making some
sort
of comeback um in in the reboot because
people want to know where they are you
know you know um
um and i think it's uh senator kinsey
thank you
um i think it's um really interesting to
sort of
touch base on this because they didn't
just disappear we know there was some
living on earth and things so the gold
is still around
and they're not stupid so it'd be really
interesting to see
where they are now and would they try to
insidiously
get power back on earth somehow or
control the lucian alliance again or
something along those lines might be
interesting
um
[Music]
wasn't the second gate destroyed yes it
was it was destroyed
um
just they just a man's tapping destroyed
style style didn't you which is that was
one of my favorite episodes um
so set in the near future a post reveal
story dealing with the consequences of
all knowledge and tech dumped on
present-day earth while we get to run
the galaxy see
talking this long dries your throat
um
i think we would this
against the crosstalk again tell me what
you think about if we go into the
storyline that brad wright's talking
about
the gate is open knowledge and um i
don't know if you're going from a video
i did a little while ago and that i saw
or i've been told about some of the
preliminary art and the gate isn't at
cheyenne mansion anymore it's actually
in like a big it looks like an airport
big glass and steel thing
um so it looks like it's an open secret
all right you know not a secret anymore
also we've got starships flying around
everywhere
and very powerful starships
um it's not 100 clear how much of the
asgard technology survived or how much
the asgard core survived
um
but we we might have that so we're going
to have technologically advanced
massively if you think about how like i
said earlier how much do we
technologically advance from the start
star get s21 to the end of sg1 it's been
another 15 years so we're going to
advance how much further
so
what what would we do as a species
knowing what people are like
what militaries are like
what would we are we still going to be
the good guys in the galaxy
are the jaffa nation and ellucian
alliance actually got something to worry
about because like say our ships can
wipe them out
and we've got the best asgard weapons
they ever developed on our ships now we
can destroy them we can destroy anything
basically that we come up against at the
moment so how would we act as a species
would we be trying to dominate them
um you know would we
just go through the thing asgard some
pegasus galaxy the race car encounters
gas
wow guys you're really getting into the
common sense it's fantastic
i've heard this story before about an
idea about a gold world and a wraith
um and again i think the gold are going
to be trying to do something to get back
on top
i'm still thinking the replicators are
out there again this is one of those
things isn't that we're going to see
some of the old villains like we are
through star trek and picard at the
moment with the ball come back
we're going to see that at some point i
think
um i found the death of the elves i saw
a really interesting video actually on
um
might have been gay world where i might
not have been about whether the asgard
actually lost
um because they basically committed
suicide didn't they um to to protect the
technology but you know and that the
genetics thing
real-life federation of aliens see that
that's me would it be a federation of of
species or would it always be dominating
species because we've got the best guns
we've got the biggest guns i don't know
but guys
that has been a recap of everything we
know and everything that's rumored at
the moment i still think
that um
cliff victoria that nothing's been
announced
and but there are rumors that it'll be a
species called the anunnaki which is
based on sumerian history um so please
get go google that it's quite a common
um ancient aliens story basically
and but that's not um announced yet it's
just a rumor
so
we are the fifth race and we're going to
become the fifth race and i think that
would be a really interesting thing to
see how we get on with over the next few
years
um
but but yeah so i'm gonna call that a
night guys unless there's anything that
pops up quickly in the next two minutes
just because i i wanted to
have this update where we go through
everything we know and everything was
rumored
um but more importantly to have a real
think about and i want to interact with
you guys and sort of anything that i
wasn't clear on that we could we could
talk about and i think we've done that a
little bit which is really great i'll do
these little live chats a little bit
more often
particularly when it comes to stargate
because they're great and if you guys
want to do i would love to do a video
where we talk about some of our favorite
videos our favorite episodes of stargate
and i've started to do that already i
did do the first series i'm actually the
second series
the second series of stargate sg-1 i was
trying to pick my favorite episode and
actually it's hard
and i don't it's only going back and
sort of looking at them written down
that you realize
how many really truly great episodes are
in that second series you know that the
first time we see the asgardia in that
series um as uh um
thor's hammer episode is in that series
which is a fantastic episode you know
there's um there's probably five six
seven
properly outstanding episodes of sci-fi
in that series which i think you always
get one or two in any good show
i did a review on firefly recently um
which is another show that i'm hoping is
going to
i'll make it 50 of that i may be hoping
it's going to return um
yeah
um so um
i meant too much about whether or not
firefighter returned or not but if it
does um that's one of those series if
you look at what the 14 episodes they
did
three or four of those episodes are
truly outstanding not just good five
episodes outstanding sci-fi episodes
full stop the second series of star
games g1
has that and it's so unusual and it's
it's really that is the the series for
me that made sg1 um a great series and
really the first series really no set
the set foundation and the second series
they absolutely nailed from beginning to
end there's no filler episodes in that
series it's just great episode after
great episode
okay
thank you guys
don't touch firefly but still the
original fire file still be there don't
worry
you can still watch it
instead of some other crap called
firefly that we all hate i'll tell you
actually before i go
talk about woke really really quickly
so
i'm not a big if you've if you've seen
my videos before you'll know i'm not a
big believer and i don't get very angry
about work
people are getting really really angry
about lord of the rings it hasn't even
been released yet
i'm pretty sure they haven't finished
making it yet
and people are already getting really
really angry about it
can i just ask
as a favor
let's not get angry about something
until i've actually seen it
and then and then let's you know let's
talk about it um yes it is it's owned by
disney but it's still owned by fox but
fox run by disney
um
so um
let's
let's talk about i guess you are and but
i'm talking about your favorite subjects
um
let's not get angry about
us something being woke or something
being whatever until we actually have
seen the show
it doesn't matter what color people are
it doesn't matter what that sex is it
doesn't learn anything you know let's
just let's let's watch the show with an
open mind and then
decide whether we love or hate it
um star trek is terrible other shows you
know quantum leap might be great we
don't know yet i do love marvel i'm
afraid i'm a huge marvel fan um i
you know
just i just love
you know um i love everything marvel
shows the movies i think they've done
such a great job
um with the marvel series um
that you can't ask for anything about
um yeah see let's we've already seen
what it's all about we haven't they
haven't even finished making it yet
let's let them finish making it
and then let's get angry about it
um you know we can always get into these
shows but
let's let's make it first let them let
me
let's let's go with an open mind you
know
um it might be
a great show it might be a load of
rubbish i went into picard series two
with an open mind
i hated picard series one
i was so disappointed by it and i know a
lot of people got angry about the woke
on that and i didn't really notice it i
noticed the bad writing
and how badly it was it was made and i
really noticed the end the the last
episode was ridiculous it was stupid um
the ships were terrible the bad guy with
the tentacles going through that was
just bad um the woke bit didn't really
bother me
um i barely noticed it
picard series two i thought no i'm going
to give it a chance
you know um they're not doing another
church dreadful that last one was oh i
heard about this isn't there gonna be
isn't that one of the reasons why star
trek four might be screwed because he's
going to do jude street instead um mccoy
and his name is going out mad um
it was unfortunate the end of series was
just bad but you know it's
i've i've i've just seen episode series
four and it's that's deadly picard
series episode one fantastic i got so
excited that yes star trek is back
stock except for two okay it's not great
but it's still really good started
episode episode three
episode four like i have for god's sake
they've done it again
you know this is like
i just i just wish they hadn't
you know i just i just i just wish they
could stop
sometimes it feels like they're trying
to be clever and sometimes i just think
now it may not bother me but it will
bother the majority fans i don't think
it does bother the majority of fans
bad writing and boring story lines
bother the majority of fans
there is a loud minority that shout woke
a lot
and a lot of the time you've got a point
but also a lot of the time sci-fi has
always been work
it's just a different name for it it's
enlightened so all the best life i
should be enlightened
and there are a lot of writers in all
genres sci-fi and everything else that
are scared
to
um
not have
black people in and asian people in and
and gay people in china because it gets
pointed out
somebody pointed out to me that friends
one of my favorite tv shows in history
is actually incredibly racist there's no
black people in it ever
so i think and it's certainly you know
why there's these six white people
running around having sex with israel
constantly it's like
you know where was the enlightenment i
never noticed when i was watching it
didn't care
now i'm like oh that's good i got point
there are tv series unfortunately there
are writers that are terrified
of a minority group having a golden um i
understand the fear
but
it's it's it's still there and it's you
know um
it doesn't
there's always been good sci-fi good bad
sci-fi um you know there's always been
sci-fi that is trying to ram an agenda
down our throat there's a lot of sci-fi
that's very political particularly
during the cold war
um and other conflicts and the good news
is propaganda and that's still happening
today it still happens
but that doesn't mean that everything
is like that because the good sci-fi
will float to the surface just like the
cream and the milk it'll flow to the
surface
um
let's have a look i couldn't care less
about color or sexual bias of people in
series but don't make the episode just
about that get some sci-fi venture into
and now i would completely agree with
that
i think i basically think that's two
sides of the same coin though for me
because i would argue that that's bad
writing
when um it's
star trek discovery
which we know has had this problem
and they make a big point about gender
neutral or whatever else
and it becomes a big part of the episode
rather than actually being um for what
hasn't actually been any story
um but it's not it's not the whole
thing it's not everything that happens
that's not everything that happens in
star trek they just happen certain
episodes like that
tng had certain episodes that were like
things like that so
anyway
that's my opinion i don't think it's as
big a problem as some people think it is
i think it is a problem
um but i really really think
we need to calm down and not scream
about stuff that hasn't even been made
yet
let's let's let's make it
let's watch it with an open mind let's
see we'll go there
there is a strong um i don't know about
chronicles of riddick tv series ian but
they are definitely making another movie
um which i'm hoping is more like
chronicles of riddick and less like
riddick because riddick seemed to me
just being like basically a may a remake
of pitch black
um which i i wasn't a massive fan of but
the chronicles of rick is genuinely one
of my favorite sci-fi movies though it's
great um and the film is going to be
called fleurian isn't i think um it's
furious so i think it will be more like
chronicles heroic than
um
the other film
let's have a look stargate may have bad
time because nasa will have the hype
with the new moon mission or could go
mingle well
we're going to end on this point sci-fi
is about it's pretty much as popular
as it's been for 20 years at the moment
it's massively popular
all of the streaming services are going
to have to have or are going to want a
big sci-fi franchise paramount plus
star trek obviously
i think it's one of the reasons why hbo
max wants um the expanse if amazon
decided to make it they would quite
happily take it
and why um they probably want babylon 5.
um disney have obviously got marvel and
star wars they're greedy um and i
actually think amazon prime will want
stargate netflix maybe has stranger
things and a couple of other projects
they're trying to do and last airbender
are saying this seems to be something
they really work on
whenever you get big excitement and the
moon mission is going to cause that sort
of thing is going to cause a lot of
people to be more interested in this
but things like
over the last two years um alien
sightings have gone up like 200 in new
york because people were locked in their
houses looked at their windows and they
kept seeing they kept thinking they've
seen aliens whether they've seen aliens
or not
there's a big interest in it
big sci-fi and supernatural shows like
ghost hunting shows and things i seem to
be reappearing again on our screens that
they didn't before then you know they
were disappearing off our screens
um but they're simply making a
re-emergence a lot of youtube channels
get massive views that talk about ghosts
and ghosts ghost hunting and aliens and
all this sort of thing because people
are really interested in it for the
first time in ages
all genres and things go through ebbs
and flows you know sci-fi drops of
popularity then increases in popularity
at the moment it's definitely on a
massive increase people love sci-fi and
only streaming services have to have a
big sci-fi franchise
it's just which one
is going to be
which one is going to be successful
um so we'll have to wait and see
all right guys i have absolutely adored
talking to you guys
um i'm gonna
finish my beer
and i'm gonna get some sleep because
i've got work tomorrow
um thank you so so much for all of your
comments and all of your chats please
carry on commenting and carry on
chatting um anything you want to see or
anything you want me to come on and talk
about in the future i will and any news
i get about stargate i will get it to
you as quickly as a human that can i do
will give you a little tease we've got a
couple of videos coming up one is about
a massive
franchise talking about aliens and
things
might be reappearing
video coming soon
and um and and a couple of videos on
stargate and star trek thank you so much
for everybody that's contributed this
evening and i will see you all really
really soon thanks guys bye